Good morning, John. I'm out for a hike with Catherine and Lemon.
What's the difference between a hike and a walk? This is definitely harder than my average
walk
going uphill.
I  want to make a couple of points in this video today.
Neither of them have anything to do with what's going on around me
but hopefully, you will find that stuff interesting as well.
We're out here hunting for wildflowers,
and we're also looking for a geocache.
Geocaching is fun.
You know what geocaching reminds me of?
It reminds me of YouTube.
A lot of cool people coming together and doing fun things and sometimes you know
troll comes in and spoils it for everybody.
But most the time, there's just a lot of people who want to do something fun together.
Geocaching, for those who don't know,
is this little practice of hiding stuff and then leaving the GPS coordinates behind
and then people can come and find your cache
and they can add stuff to the cache and take stuff out of the cache
and leave their name in the logbook.
It's super fun.
I was going to show you me finding the geocache,
but I can't find it,
which is embarrassing.
One of the two big points that I want to make in this video though, is that
YouTube is important.
YouTube is important, interesting and fascinating on so many levels,
and it's freaking awesome.
But here's my real point.
LOTS
of stuff is important.
Mountains are important.
Oxygen is important.
PVC pipes are important.
Motherboards are important.
Motherhood is important.
And all of these things are important.
Saying that what you're doing is important
isn't unusual.
The second thing that I want to add to this
is that important doesn't equal serious.
I think personally fun is like the most important thing out there,
except for trying to make the world a better place.
Fun, man!
And I get so angry
when people start to make it about being serious
because you know what?
Fun is important.
Stephenie Meyer is important.
Austin Powers is important.
Weird Al Yankovic is important.
And I don't care who hears me say it.
John and nerdfighters,
I think that we are all so lucky to be in new media,
where we don't have to take things so seriously.
And the last thing I want, honestly, is for THIS to become serious business,
because then you start to lose the fun.
FUUUUUUN.
Ah!
Ahhh!
There's a log in that.
Fun and beautiful.
That's what I want for us.
I cannot express
how lucky I feel
that I can go outside on a beautiful day, and share my thoughts with so many interesting and thoughtful people.
So lucky
and I hope that we can distinguish between important
and serious
because to me,
serious has never even been on the agenda.
What's on the agenda
is important
fun.
This is important fun.
Let's have it!
John, I will see you on Friday.
We found it.
[Whispering] We found it.
Isn't that exciting?
Look!
Right there.
This is the logbook.